that if you're if her temperature
doesn't go down we're gonna have to give
her this medication of sorts that will
either make her blind or deaf if her
temperature goes down we won't give it
to her and the next morning my
temperature dropped and they didn't give
me that drug otherwise I would be blind
or deaf right now but I had a learning
disability from the meningitis my whole
life that's something that I had to like
work through myself there's no cure for
that you just find other ways to in
school I would just memorize textbooks I
didn't actually fully understand
everything I memorized it so I could get
straight A's
so you find your own way and I think
that's why I went into acting because it
was memorization it was becoming someone
that you're not
I was always embarrassed in school like
they'd pull me out for testing I had
these surveyors that followed me for
years through like elementary school so
yeah it really [ __ ] with who I was as
a kid but sort of made me who I am now
Jesus yeah I mean I remember stuff that
you've told me but that and when you say
a learning disability as a kid I always
felt like I was just stupid I couldn't
comprehend things I'd read things and I
just because the a D D and hey like when
you went you so you could quickly
memorize things but you wouldn't be able
to pump like absorb them I did depends
what it was there was a lot that I was
able to fully understand and absorb and
was very much into but things like I
couldn't tell time I didn't understand a
clock are you looking for a clock right
now that's right time math I'm
directionally challenged still like I
have I still write no not like that but
like minore Thor so I just I'm it's very
different for me and there are a lot of
people who have the same disability
where you it's not like you're dyslexic
but you have trouble and you flip things
so my whole life my goal was to appear
to be like everyone else
right which [ __ ] with you when you're
trying to be like everyone else and not
yourself so that now as an adults I
still struggle with people and I - I
don't want them to think of me
differently but at the same time I want
to
it's it's a weird thing it definitely
molded me in a way that I'm insecure
about stuff I have social anxiety
alright people all right so here's the
thing though